so how about that debate awesome right
turns out all it took was a little Chum
to get the Sharks feeding which is what
Bloomberg was the little Chum who got
eaten alive a billionaire who calls
women fat broads and horse-faced
lesbians and no I'm not talking about
Donald Trump I'm talking about Mayor
Bloomberg I thought that he shouldn't be
hiding behind his TV ads he got
stop-and-frisk throwing up close to five
million young black men up against a
wall we are sick and tired of
billionaires like mr. Bloomberg seeing
huge expansions of their wealth while a
half a million people sleep out on the
street tonight Mayor Bloomberg who
thinks he can buy this election we have
a very few non-disclosure agreements how
many I may finish how many of them I
haven't seen someone look more out of
place since Jesse went to confession
meanwhile those who feasted on mini Mike
benefited not only did Bloomberg not
have a box he didn't know how to box
caught flat-footed at each turn he
exhibited the agility of a corpse
Liz led the attack relentlessly Biden
for once seems semi-coherent Amy Kay
took the opportunity to clobber the word
faucet that is mayor Pete but the big
winner Bernie who barely got touched
because everyone wanted a piece of the
billionaire Sanders was like a magician
benefiting from misdirection here
everyone look at laughable mini Mike
while I steal the nomination of course
Mike had it coming you don't enter late
in the game throw cash at the crowd then
tell those who've already been playing
to drop out because you arrived plus his
reputation is piggish but it's a
sobering observation among Democrats
it's worse being a billionaire who
started businesses than an apologist for
the Soviet Union during the Cold War
because the Cold War was like history
and that was 31 years ago a long time so
maybe Bernie just forgot like all of his
supporters did that's scary for the rest
of us who prefer capitalism over
socialism who rooted for America not the
USSR in the 70s and 80s who see that
success in competition and profit jobs
and incentives can actually change lives
sadly Bloomberg worked hard and all he
got was rich he never stood a chance all
right can we just admit Dagan that that
was so much fun it was so I was having a
blast last night it was a little hard to
watch like in my part in my private time
I watch super car crash fails where you
have this arrogant rich guy who gets
behind the wheel of like a six or a
seven figure car yeah and because he's a
clown and a jerk yes and full of himself
he wrecks the car he and I derive deep
immense amounts of pleasure from
watching that but even last night this
was so awkward and painful I think
people will have pity on him and they
will give Mike Bloomberg a second chance
but you I've been where he's been you're
you're getting up there an age and you
get inside of your own head and all
you're thinking about is don't be an ass
don't be an ass don't yell at her don't
yell at her and you can't do anything
else because you're just stuck in your
own noggin well you do you do you think
this hurts him I mean I hurts him but do
you think it knocks him out I don't
think it knocks him out and I don't
think it will hurt him as much because
he's got so much money in the race now
there was a big turnout for people at
watch laughs yeah this was not your
average primary debate so people that
tuned it turn tuned in saw Mike
Bloomberg for the first time like on
stage rather than just on an ad and they
might say well gosh maybe he's not that
great but I still think you know
overnight he picked up these four
endorsements from congressional members
he got another one in South Carolina and
the thing is if he didn't have to debate
again before the voting that maybe he
could hang on
but there's another debate in four days
but I kind of I kind of wish that he had
just let his inside voice out yes would
like Trump die does yeah and then when
they went after him on stop and first
say okay actually let me just set the
stage here he was pretty good at telling
them not to interrupt him he does not
like to be interrupted and he shut that
down and Elizabeth Warren I think look
you know she said she hates billionaires
so much and she in her campaign she was
not gonna take money from billionaires
she had this whole thing guess what
happened today oh there's a super PAC
that wants to
donate in her name and she's not going
to disavow it right yeah everybody has
to play the game
Geraldo where do you put this in the in
performances of debates you've seen
horrifying yeah
shocking I was at I was at 21 at lunch
with my buddy David Cheryl and he said
that what they're saying on the wall
street is that he brought his wallet to
a knife fight yeah I thought it was a
shoddy performance by Mayor Bloomberg I
thought he was unprepared how could he
not be ready for the obvious attacks
that you know your grandmother knew were
coming III thought that that was the
part that seemed most shocking to me how
woefully unprepared he was I mean it's
not just I mean if you have a staff of
40 thousand people don't at least have
like two guys get to give you six
zingers right to use over to our debate
you know it's gonna be about stop and
frisk have an answer for stop and frisk
you know it's gonna be about buying your
way into the race have an answer for
buying your way into the race talk about
the struggle talk about you know your
family had nothing and this is the
American Dream and why are we putting
down the American Dream and how did we
become this nation of mediocrity where
you know success is somehow something to
be shunned I I thought that it was
really very amateur he wasn't a good he
wasn't a good proponent for capitalism
that was the problem
Jesse do you want to respond to Trump's
tweet about this or would you like to
just give your thoughts extemporaneous
well I don't care I just remember
yesterday when Geraldo said Mike was
good have a great night I didn't forget
at my age I have very short-term memory
loss yeah you're like Klobuchar he can't
remember names
I can't Lopez Obrador remember that's
right the phrase that was you kept
hearing in the media with circular
firing squad which is a cliche of course
it was it bad overall for the Dems no I
would say he injected a little
adrenaline into the field they started
showing their teeth you know they're
damn into getting a little competitive
he was kind of like a trump light up
there he's basically like a weak
Republican even a nice fat target and
they took advantage of it but I mean he
paid 400 million dollars for that
beatdown yes maybe
he's into that kind of thing I don't
know what I would have done it for half
that yeah I know he probably wishes he
had a little box to battle under after
that performance
he just didn't live up to the hype the
guy was shaky he was unprepared and what
you wanted to see out of Mike you talked
about this you just mentioned it he
wanted to see a boss out yeah and he
acted like an intern if Liz Warren says
show us your NDA he should have said
well no well you showed us your DNA and
that didn't work out well you called
this woman a horse tooth lesbian he
would have should have said only the
royal family was about only Rosie
O'Donnell
talking about the consultants I could
have given him a line if she was gonna
bring that up he could have said didn't
just last week your staff in Las Vegas
here in Las Vegas leave because of a
hostile workplace yes because that was
that happen we should be running his
campaign we could spending all that
money and I think that because it's one
thing to not be on the debate stage but
he also doesn't do any interviews to get
himself into a little bit of fighting
shape yeah that DNA line is a winner
yep I mean I would have sold that to him
from could I tell you as soon as it was
over it was a spot on an advertisement
for Bloomberg and it's like and then
they was doing this morning when I woke
up yeah soon there's gonna be fire to
all of that he burned half a billion
dollars on a debate stage last night all
over again one hundred and twentieth of
is well it's like false advertising
because you now you see this bloom
you're gonna add and it's not the guy
you saw last night yeah all right